[音楽]
info ます
今日は川島娘と申しますよろしくお願いします
今回ワードおおっ
まあ僕は好きだの鉄道会社
実働会社社長お店電話
お話ししていきたいなと思います
まぁこりゃーの
僕は書いたマーシュマークラフ
グラフなんですけどまぁこっちからねおやつけどドーム鉄道西武鉄道
っていうふうにはグラフで表したんですけど
まあ
な女だけどはデパートと
ウェバーとドラック東武鉄道はデパートとすれば
西武鉄道はプリンス皇帝とかのホテル事業を稼い
は利益を出していて
キャリアのなかでは
それであの意外と雪道会社のまあ売上の割合っていうのは医学鉄道事業は34割ぐらい
で
鳳凰ほぼ全体ができ同事業で稼いでいるって会社はまあ
アーマ低下
だいたい他の事業で稼いでいるということを曲が多いんですけど残念なが経営が
立ち行かなくなった会社も無事
もちろんたくさんあり
その中の一つでは誰かジム鉄道という会社があるんですけど
まあ
ぶしゃま台風の続税
まあもう売っ9
もう復旧できない状態になってもう廃人になってしまった
実働会社なんですけど
このこの会社をどうにかまあいいよというか
復旧復旧して何か内海使えないだろうかとか
それを色々考えました
最初はすごい今
くり大東はお金がかかりすぎるとか色々考えてましたけど
ほんと最初のほうは鉄道網この鉄道地でがッスレってことを考えてなんですけどまぁ
途中 da こう思いました
鉄道以外を移動しだってあるよね
そうだバスにしようと思いました
まあ僕これはもう自分の趣味もあるんですけど
まあこういう
いるるー
ぎょっ結構こういう条件にば座っていて
まずこういう無尺税とかやってもうまあ
道路される旧できるは走り始めるしそもそもはれ道路され本当にいろんなところに
遠く遠くの街とかでも行けて鉄道本当っ
戦後がないとどこにも行けないっていう兄弟でお金も
くっ
車重全体的わかるかかるお金も少ないし
こういう地方
地方だからこそこういうのが生かせるんじゃないかなと思いました
その次に
僕はい全国47機と付けるが続かんという方を
まあだしたんですけどまぁそのこの方は
まああの
まあ方タイトル同意なんですけどまぁと雲泥なんと does けどまぁ
まあ1県1回施術っていう
ので場所を書いていきました
その中でもまあ僕が好きな感じでは西鉄バスっていうまあ日本最大系って結構名前を
もうしなりている方は多いと思うんです
まあなぜ好きかと言われたら
あの正社員さんは運転たんですねその脅威がとってもしっかり入って生てるんじゃねー
から
あのっ
まず自社である教習所を持っていて
それでよく西鉄ば cnt んさんが止まっていまー
運転の根絶だったりとかあとよくバラエティ番組んとかユース番組にも
よく出ててそこによく運転のギリスとかダサイってすごいいいかじゃなあと
思ったりして
ツナ理由に出したほうが
んですけどまぁに施設系ノーマンにシティスペンディング高速バスターミナルというお
お
ちゃうといいですね
心屋の
まあにしてざいます以外にもまあ他の罰会社で他の高速バスの会社も書いたんですけど
まぁいろんなところにここから走ってるんじゃないっていうかわかりました
その後にまあウィラーエクスプレスについて調べてみたという本を出したんですけど
前までは基本的にバスの車体
とかまぁとショートが二重注目
注目流が基本的そういうのを変えていったんですけど今回の視点を変えても
バスのシートにこだわって書いてみて
ウィラーエクスプレスはホント色んな結構は近距離もあるんですけど基本的に長距離の
薬を高速バスを出していっ
運行している会社で正夜行高速バスだとまぁ短くても6時間くらいさって言うわけです
ねやっぱりバスの中で麻薬をだから
夜行高に new と思うんですけどずっと6時間
詰まっ座りな元でるって言うのは本当にちょっといい種
ちょっといいシートで本当に意見を伝えることなんで
沿い旧国風がいるんですけどウェア
考えられたシートがある
特注で作っててすごくお客さんの目線で
立ってるいい会社だなと思うんですけど you
まあ僕まあその中でいっぱい種類があるんですけどその中では一番すごいなあと思うの
が
このリボンというシートデー
はいん
結構汁汁の中に座席あるって言うとまぁわかりたいと思うんですけどこういう
保護してみたいな感じか壊れてて
ついたくその
その汁の中でだけで行くライニングして
まあ結構白中田と最大限はいくらイニングできるしなによりも本当に知る仲だから後ろ
の人に迷惑がかからない
すなわちあのいくらは自分の前の席の人が
リクライニングしたとしても自分の足下が字幕なるってことも無いいなくてとっても
イージーだなぁと思って
他にもが
方枕みたいな首宛てだっているか音声と
あとドリームフォルダーだったりあと
まあ小さいテーブルなどもあって
本当にう考えられたシートだなと思いました
これはの僕が幼稚園の頃つつ園のときに書いてあるばむ
でまぁ将来はどの人いったいどんな人でが何になりたいかっていう機会って書いたん
ですけど
僕は園長先生に会いたいときましたかそれで
前まで幼稚園の先生になりと言ってした多かったけど
園長先生になりたいという人初めて見たよとすごい喜んでくれましたよね
でも
でもどうしてなりたいかって思う人もいると思うんですけど
まあよチェーンによチェーンで園長先生た浮かっていうのは基本的には用事があったり
とか
あとはまあ色1なってみるぐらいで結構
アン機会は少ないですねなんか基本的に普通の先生とバッカーんですよ
だから雨
園長先生というまあ身近にいるって言っちゃった悪いかな
まあそういう
あまり自分の人は近くにいる感じがしないって言う
まあ存在だったんですけど
それであのよちょっと話が変わってるんですけど幼稚園バスが停まっている駐車場が
あって
まあたまに家へますが出たりする時は
院長先生のレクサスが止まっていることがあった
他の先生よ見る機会少ないレクサスに乗って羽振りよさそう
はいいよねーっそういう間
そういう考えで炎上爺がたいと思ったから
その後色々マーチっこいこういうのになりたいなとかいろいろ考えて
まあ
今今の目標は経営者とかそういうのを目指しています
まあ話話は変わるんですけど実は僕
まあ学校に行ってないまあいわゆる不登校という状態で
まあ結構多い
まあここまで話を聞いてくれた方はあの
到着の話が合わなかった言いてたりしてしてたんだろうなーって思ってれば
人もいるかもしれませんがまあそりゅーまあそれもまあ少しありますが結構他の理由を
他の理由もあっては今学校にあり行けてません
でも
僕の周りのまあが今の先生はもちろん周りの音だ
自分
お父さんお母さんが僕のことを色々支えたりしておくれたおかげでいい
今た今普通の勉強はもちろん自分の本当に学びたい
例えば木8カウントですねそういうことを楽しく学びと本当に幸せです
そのさっきさっき言った支えてくれている大人っていうのは今ここで聞いてくれている
皆さんのことでもあります
本当に最後まで聴いて増えたのと一緒に本当にありがとうございました
[拍手]